l'un des messieurs bonsoir l'épineux
dossier du niqab poursuit thomas mulcair
jusque dans le grand nord où il faisait
campagne aujourd'hui des voix
discordantes au sein même de ses troupes
s'élèvent pour se distancier de la
position de leur chef
encore une fois thomas mulcair a dû
répondre aux questions je joins tout de
suite julie dufresne qui est à ical week
julie ça va déjà pas tellement bien pour
monsieur mulcair voilà un nouveau pavé
dans la mare oui et céline vous l'avez
dit on a beau être aussi loin qu à
iqaluit et il semble que cette
controverse sur le niqab continue de
poursuivre le chef du npd et ça fait mal
à sa campagne il faut le dire parce que
bon on a vu déjà dans les derniers jours
que les appuis au québec pour le npd
commence à sérieusement diminué et voilà
que trois candidats des candidats du
québec ou s'ils annoncent qu'ils le font
à préoccupés par la position officielle
du parti sur la question du niqab
ces candidats donc roméo saganash
danielle landreville et pierre nantel
qui l'ont dit donc publiquement lors des
débats et dans des entrevues
parce que ce qu'il va entendre sur le
terrain lorsqu'ils font du porte à porte
c'est que ça dérange les électeurs et
c'est comme s'il tentait céline un peu
de se dissocier de leur cher peut-être
parce qu'ils ont peur de perdre leur
élection
alors ce soir évidemment la question a
été posée thomas mulcair qu'il faut le
dire il est resté quand même somme toute
relativement calmes pour y répondre
et sur le fond sa position demeure la
même forme qu'on a senti qu'il voulait
quand même plus clairement exprimé son
malaise avec toute cette question ce que
moi je sais c'est que les québécois
veulent vivre dans une société ouverte
où tous et chacun est respecté mais les
gens expriment un malaise avec le niqab
en particulier un malaise qui est
partagé largement y compris par moi même
mais c'est plus une question d'aimer ça
ou pas et me sens une fois que les
tribunaux ont statué et je lis faut dire
que toute cette histoire qui fait si mal
à thomas mulcair elle concerne très peu
de femmes en fête et c'est là que
c'était important céline de bien
remettre les choses en perspective parce
que selon les informations que nos
équipes ont obtenu auprès de citoyenneté
et immigration canada il y en fait
depuis 2011 seulement 2
femmes qui ont refusé de prêter serment
pour obtenir leur citoyenneté canadienne
parce qu'elle tenait à porter leur niqab
alors deux femmes sur 680 milles ça
céline ça représente 0 point 0 0 0 0 0
3% des femmes donc qui ont pas pu prêter
serment pour cette raison là le problème
donc ce n'est pas ça le problème en fait
c'est que ça commence à sérieusement
embêté les candidats néo démocrates qui
sont inquiètes pour leurs campagnes leur
campagne et ce qu'on sent aussi sur la
caravane néo-démocrate c'est que ça
agace les stratèges parce qu en fait
thomas mulcair est pris avec la
perception et c'est important lors d'une
campagne électorale
la perception donc que son parti n'est
pas assez ferme sur la question du niqab
et c'est un problème qui va devoir être
réglé très rapidement parce qu'il ya un
débat qui s'en vient dans quelques jours
et le npd le chef du npd doit absolument
reprendre le contrôle de son agenda
d'ici là oui le cinquième et dernier
débat de cette campagne donc en principe
en tout cas le vendredi merci beaucoup
julie je vous en prie au revoir